the third episode of the final season as
you can see this script page looks
exactly like the one from Season seven
that turned out to be quite accurate
however if you don't want anything
spoiled it's time for you to close this
video this script starts with the guts
with off interval it's night John and
Danny hold hands as they stand side by
side before the sacred we would heart
tree
it says the seven Percy so tie ribbon in
a knot around our joint hands which
symbolizes their union I hereby seal
these two souls binding them as one for
eternity curse beetles would seek to
tear them apart Sutton says the scene
then switches to King's Landing it's not
only John and Danny that are getting
married it's also Cersei and urine it
says as the Septon speaks we see a shot
of the wedding ceremony in the Great
Hall Cersei and urine are getting
married as well and it's Qyburn who has
them married the scene that switches
back to the godswood of interval Septon
continues look upon each other and say
the words John and Danny look upon one
another and start reciting their vows
both of them speaking simultaneously say
father Smith warrior mother maiden Crone
stranger - this still speaking
simultaneously Johnny the nearside their
main vows if this leaks her page turns
out to be true episode 3 of the final
season will witness two major weddings I
know that this script might cause some
confusion among viewers since John and
Danny seem to have a fate of the same
style wedding ceremony given that John
seems to closely follow the old gods of
the forest like his family this should
not be surprising since either sir
himself married Kathleen the faith of
the seven style wedding
so did rob and ELISA however in closer
inspection it seems as if Johnson Dana's
wedding is a hybrid of the faith of the
seven and old God's wedding ceremonies
it's not performed in a set at all but
seems to be held in the local gods were
in front of a weirwood tree moreover
faith of the same wedding ceremonies are
typically held during the day while
John's and Dana's wedding is seemingly
held at night which is actually how old
God style wedding ceremonies are
conducted anyways if you've been
watching my previous videos this vetting
of Ice and Fire isn't a huge surprise
for you neither is a marriage between
Cersei and urine
additionally marriage of Ice and Fire is
expected to already take place in the
previous season of Game of Thrones
considering that the potential suitor in
Westeros was the main reason Dany left
her lover Daario naharis behind him
marine in the season 6 finale
people have been shipping John and Danny
basically since the very beginning of
the show however Game of Thrones Season
7 did see Ice and Fire come together as
just know in the near Targaryen finally
met and promptly
since then he did not come to Westeros
only concrete but also to build a stable
order and reunite all the seven kingdoms
of each mustering and open rebellion
against the crown Jon Snow was and still
is the only logical suitor for Dany John
and Danny have already begun an intimate
relationship although neither one of
them is currently aware of their family
ties since John and Danny are headed to
Winterfell it's likely that Brandon
similar will the truth about Joshu
heritage early on in the season
clearly this revelation of Danny being
Jones and will come as a huge shock to
both of them Ellen will certainly change
their relationship even though
incestuous pairings have never bought a
Targaryen sense some might even say that
it will not bother John and then either
as their Targaryen themselves you're
completely wrong Targaryen did spend
over 300 years wearing brothers a sister
in order to keep their bloodline pure
then his parents Ares the Mad King and
relevance if Lynx and Daenerys did grow
up believing she would marry her brother
Viserys also true but it simply is not
the same
even though intermarriage is accepted in
Westeros and expected for Targaryen
John was not raised as a Targaryen and
likeable not embrace their family
traditions throughout the show it's been
established at first the green cells
outside the Targaryen family such as
crest rang his daughters and of course
the most popular incest couple Jaime and
Cersei is considered wrong and immoral
intermarriage between first cousins on
the other hand is not consider incest in
Westeros a society a prominent example
of this is time Lannister who murdered
his own cousin Joanna Lannister matter
of all three of his children however
John and Danny are not cousins nor their
siblings their nephew and aunt and
therefore many have been wondering if
they will upon finding out the truth
still merry chatter to seal their
alliance the answer on that question is
both yes and no yes there will be
Targaryen marriage as the leak through
page says but no they were not married
to seal their alliance but rather
because of their child I know you might
be a bit confused so let's get a little
bit back I doubt John and Danny will
continue their intimate relationship
after they found out the truth which
will by the way take place in the very
beginning of the final season but they
don't have to because Daniel already got
pregnant in the season 7 finale
despite the nurses believed that she
cannot have children because of the
prophecy that was told to her in the
very first season Danny will most
definitely be pregnant with John's baby
next time you see her
and your family hasn't seen its end
you're still here I can't have children
who told you that
the witch related my husband has it
occurred to you she might not have been
a reliable source of information just as
john snap stated it's highly possible at
the which was not being honest with
Danny Mitchell long with a lot of our
shadows that took place in previous
season might mean that the season finale
brings more surprises than we hope for
your father gave me this change the
Palmer from a pair to a wolf but it's
still long claw
look him out in a moment so you never
come back to Westeros where you are back
and it's been in your family for
centuries it's not right for me to have
it
he gave it to you I'm not his son
[Music]
I brought shame into my house it broke
my father's heart I've forfeited the
right to claim this soul
it's yours it's Furby well get children
after you so Dane is most likely
pregnant all expectant Targaryen
marriage but having on mind that John
will most certainly find out about his
show parentage almost at the same time
the nurse tells him that they're about
to have a baby
quite amount of fans also doubt that
this marriage will actually take place
well this marriage is most definitely
happening because Danny's pregnant I
know we are still wondering how does the
nearest being pregnant change the fact
that their lated which of course it
doesn't and therefore why would they
marry but give me a few moments to
explain too even though both of them
will without a doubt refuse to even
think about marriage whether it's
political or out of love in the
beginning of the season upon learning
that their nephew and and they'll have
even stronger reasons to do so later in
the season and that reason is going to
be Danny's pregnancy once they learn of
their family ties the other news well
hidden already mentioned Anne's
pregnancy with John's baby and that
exact news will make them change their
mind and actually marry each other and
here's why John has been a bastard son
his entire life and he most certainly
will not allow his child to be born out
of wedlock and live a life he's been
living both in the book series and on
the show Johnny initially refuses to
sleep with women because he's absolutely
terrified that he might produce a
bastard for example in the fourth
episode of the very first season there
was a small talk between John and Sam on
Sam's assumption that John has probably
hundreds of girls so far John answered
with no he hasn't
Genting goes on to describe his only
chance with a girl he says so I said
there in the brothel as ROS to cover
clothes but I couldn't do it because all
I could think was what if I got her
pregnant and she had a child another
bastard named snow it's not a good life
for a child the fact that John himself
is not actual a bastard but illegitimate
son of Rhaegar Targaryen rule in Turkish
wear to the Iron Throne is highly ironic
of course but it doesn't change the way
he grew up it most definitely will not
change his desire not to bring another
bastard named snow into the world
therefore this marriage of Ice and Fire
does not come as a huge surprise taking
into consideration that Dane is pregnant
and John on the other hand would never
allow his child to be a bastard now
let's say a few words about the wedding
between the mad Queen Cersei Lannister
and Euron Greyjoy that is seemingly
taking place at the same time of John's
and anus as we all know in the beginning
of season seven upon having failed to
meet Dana urine sales the armed flee to
King's Landing answering the invitation
of Cersei Cersei proposes and allegiance
between the crown and the Ironborn which
he encounters with an offer of may
circe decline students and tempteth
courtship and he departs promising to
return with a gift at filming her heart
as we all know urine did fulfill his
promise by heading her the people
responsible for the death of her
daughter Cersei is pleased then in
return promises to grant his request of
marriage after the war if one now many
fans don't consider this marriage is a
huge twist as a matter of fact most of
us expected it after all urine did fit
some of Circe's enemies already at the
end of season 7 urine also sells vessels
to bring services the golden company to
fight for her cause however let me
remind you that Cersei promised yearn to
marry him after the war is over I have a
hard time imagining that Danny would be
defeated in the episode 3 of the final
season additionally I don't think either
one of them will be defeated before the
very final episode of Game of Thrones so
we need to ask ourselves if the war is
not over yet why start simmering urine
in the third episode taking into account
how cunning sir says and how obvious it
was that the marriage deal was just a
ploy to get urine on her side this
marriage does come as a huge surprise
for me
urine is too unpredictable for Cersei to
marry him it's clear to her that his
only interest is power the own
explanation would be sir she will not
have a choice but to marry him could it
be that urine will threaten Cersei that
he would betray her and joining his side
if she's not to marry him could it even
be that the iron bank will order Cersei
to marry Iran in order to seal their
allegiance and strengthen the Crown's
position there are many possibilities
Batman is certain this marriage is
taking place in the third episode of
season 8 and it definitely will not end
up well for one of them as soon as this
match happens both of them will most
likely try to take out the other in
order to gain total control of the
throne in conclusion if this leaks
through page turns out to be true
episode 3 of the final season will
witness two major weddings one of which
is the long waited wedding of Ice and
Fire